أجنبي ، قد يجعل شرب الماء
أسهل بالنسبة لأولئك الذين لا يهتمون به ،
الماء مهم جدًا ليس فقط
للترطيب ولكن لتكون قادرًا على
هضم طعامنا
بانتظام وأشياء من هذا القبيل بالإضافة إلى
The Tick Tock Trend لإضافة النكهة
شراب ومساحيق الماء يمكن أن تغير
مذاقه ، لكن هل هي طريقة صحية للحفاظ على
رطوبة أخصائية التغذية السريرية بريدجيت
ديوان من أورلاندو هيلث تقول إنه من
المهم الاستماع إلى إشارات العطش الخاصة بك ،
فنحن نتحدث نوعًا ما عن كل السوائل ،
لذا فإن الهدف هو حوالي 13 كوبًا  من السوائل
للذكور البالغين وحوالي تسعة أكواب للإناث
البالغات ، وهذا يشمل جميع
السوائل ، لذلك علينا أن نأخذ في الحسبان نعم ،
عدد القهوة التي تعداد الصودا ،
إذا كنت تستبدل الصودا بالماء
مع شراب أو مساحيق خالية من السكر.
الاستبدال الجيد ولكن
شرب الكثير من السوائل يمكن أن يؤدي إلى انخفاض
مستويات الصوديوم في الجسم ويؤدي
إلى حالة خطيرة تسمى
أعراض نقص صوديوم الدم وتشمل
الغثيان
أو القيء.
القليل من الماء أمر سيء ، لذا فهو
توازن جيد جدًا لما
يحتاجه جسمنا من الماء على أساس يومي إذا
كنت تقوم بتغيير
روتين الترطيب ولديك أسئلة يقول ديوان إنه من
الأفضل التحدث إلى طبيبك أو
التسجيل  اختصاصي تغذية أولًا للدقيقة الصحية
أنا ماندي جيثر